what advice do you have for another
filmmaker or producer preparing to
produce their first project what advice
would you tell them hmm that's a tough
one I would say number one everyone that
says that you can't get it done
just ignore them immediately you have
you have to believe in yourself you have
to believe in in the project itself and
if it was easy everyone would do it I
guess that's kind of a cliche to say but
I really do believe that is true it is
the trail is fraught with with potholes
and with people wanting you to sort of
wake up and get get a real job you know
and I feel like half of that is that
what you're trying to do is such a
fantasy and is so difficult to do that
you know if you had any common sense you
wouldn't even try but the other half is
I think a lot of people sort of check
out themselves you know they they but
they don't believe that they're gonna be
able to pull off these impossible things
and I just you know I think it's what is
it a Lewis Carroll quote though you have
to believe several impossible things
every morning I think you know being a
filmmaker producer you have to believe
several impossible things when you get
out of bed every morning because the
competition is very very difficult and
there are so many talented people that
are making you know projects left and
right it's really a matter of being able
to rise to the top of that group and the
first goal is to get your first project
done and I think you know get your first
project done get a group around you that
that you believe in get a group of
people that have the amount of passion
that you have because it's impossible to
maintain your own level of passion and
then have to give your energy to help
other people you know maintain their
passion so surround yourself with people
who are like insane for for the project
and and then get it done you know get
them
together get shooting don't sit around
and say one day or when this is perfect
or you know I'm gonna start shooting
when this happens I think you get the
project under your belt because there's
no better education at least in my
opinion then to get then to do it and
find out what you did wrong find out
what you did right and then gather your
forces up to do it again let's say it's
a first project so they don't have any
other project to sort of write off of or
show people what are some of the common
potholes this person's going to
experience well I mean other than money
which is which is the major pothole
because you know they're raising money
is is so difficult there are people who
people have gotten very savvy to you
know finding the richest dentist in your
town and and and raising as money cuz
now that dentist can go online and say
hey if I have you know all this money to
invest why don't I go get a famous actor
and they're looking for money too you
know so raising the money is is a huge
issue
I think there's often I would say you be
aware of defining everyone's roles you
know in the project there can be you
know if you go in there sort of
loosey-goosey there can be power
struggles you know there can be internal
struggles I would say define your roles
you know decide who's the director
decides the producer decide who you know
who is going to work on the production
design get all of that straight up front
so that when you're doing it it's all
the focuses on the project you got I
really believe you've got to create an
environment where people feel free to
collaborate and and bring you know their
artistic point of view and talents to
the table so listen to all ideas I think
is is a is a good sort of mantra and you
know you don't have to do what everyone
is telling you all the time but you
definitely want to listen
what they're saying because very often
you know five minds is better than one
no matter how smart you are so it's and
and that's what I always say is the
coolest thing about this art form is
that it is the collaboration if you're a
painter you're painting a painting but
we have not only director of photography
that's painting with lights but you have
a director who's blocking his actors and
and working with physical performance
and the actors that are doing their
emotional work and the Wardrobe
supervisors got her amazing costumes and
it's really the what I love about the
art form the best is it takes the best
of all of the art forms that exist and
puts them you know into one place so
getting a team of artists that you
really believe in is also essential
because you know those ideas I mean you
look at like a Tim Burton film it's like
would those be the same if he didn't
have the production design or the
Wardrobe that he has that's not all Tim
Burton's vision you know it's all of
those other people that he believes in
you know Woody Allen is the same crew
that he uses on all of his projects
almost because you know all those people
work together to create those those
shows and so I would say yeah get a team
around you that that you really love and
believe in and again I go back to that
whole energy level it's like you have to
have the energy for yourself you have
the energy create you can't have you
can't be using your energy to fire other
people in your team up those people have
to be as passionate
you